people they play Russian roulette with
this pill yet they literally skipped
four days and they're like four pills in
and then they get pregnant and then they
send you know like if I don't choose to
keep the child you know like that's a
thing and also like I feel like a lot of
people get their emotions caught up in
this thing like let's say yeah you're
with your boyfriend you know it's been
cheating and then you get pregnant and
then your emotions get involved you're
like oh but he's so cute on his good
days
maybe it could work it's never gonna
work because he's been cheating so or
you know if it's just not the ideal
situation then you as a woman
how much is you cannot like it you still
choose to have the baby even though the
situation is not perfect same with the
condom thing right if a guy comes at
your house you know you're doing your
thing and then it's it's time to put the
rubber on and you're and you're like oh
I'm in the moment and something happens
that's your body that's you not being
sacred with your body